fill er up you're listening to the cat
digital network and now Tim Dylan is
going to have
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to Tim no one's
going to house all right you know what
it's we're all yeah we're all doing what
we have to do good to be here again
Tim Dylan Yanis Papas one of our
favorite guys ever to be on the show
returning favorite use my proper pronoun
yeah God him him him he hands yeah mine
is that that my pronoun is that yeah I
do want to say to people before we get
into all the other things if you are a
human being with even a small life the
appropriate relationship to have the
Game of Thrones is basically to not know
what's going on yeah I've watched you
seven years I can barely explain what's
happening I know like three of the main
storylines because I have things going
on outside of that that I have to do if
you know every subplot and every family
and how they intersect and you know more
about their families than your own just
you don't have one that's a problem if
you're the one at the party who's like I
know it's Rhaegar that's the that's a
problem yeah I tweeted something today
and people got angry when viral ben
shapiro retweeted it rogue and retweeted
but i said essentially i was like listen
if you don't like the way this season a
game of thrones is going you can start a
family yeah i retweeted it yeah and stop
looking stop looking for meaning in your
life on cable yeah TV yeah and the hate
the it would be it the response to that
the response to telling people to stop
watching TV and start having kids is
basically like I said Heil Hitler
yeah that was the response I got yeah
because yeah that's that's part of the
patriarchal rise scheme is to get women
to do what all life wants to do right is
reproduce
yeah that's part of it that's part of an
old system that is unjust and needs to
be yes updated and amended yes yeah
we're not gonna let [ __ ] mother nature
tell us one
allowed to have kids we're gonna get
we're gonna go all the way 65 and we're
gonna work at HuffPo for 20 years before
we ya know we should yeah and it's great
too and we'll retire with a pitbull
rescue a rescue pitbull yeah I work at a
standing desk yeah and I have a Twitter
account that has all my pronouns in my
bio yes yeah it that seems like you and
I argue about the political implications
of Game of Thrones yeah have you ever
gone to a person's Twitter bio and seen
their pronouns there
oh yeah like yeah that that's a person
that's that's not gonna be a fun
conversation Matt if somebody puts their
pronouns
where's three of them yeah in their
Twitter bio yeah that's someone who's
not gonna be able to see your point of
view no no there will you said today
about Brooklyn was great you're like
these people don't seem fun no it
doesn't seem fun we got a real dearth of
fun people yeah I grew up around
characters long island characters yeah
and we're driving those people out and I
think part of it is that because you
have social media now everything
everybody is so easy to like Corral
people into doing what you want them to
do so ease because people just see that
they're like all put they put their
pronouns up I want to do the right thing
I want to be considerate I'll put my
print you know and and then you just get
it flattens everybody it's like the
great flattening where everybody's the
same yeah and you said that the other
night we were driving home it's like
that's what that's what the goal is
gonna be is like to get everyone to be
the same and flawless right everyone is
acting like they're flawless and if you
show a flaw they DeMott did they
punished you for having a flaw yeah you
know but but a flaw is what makes you a
person and makes you interesting yeah
now they want to put you in jail for it
yeah and everyone's pretending like they
don't have it because they got a short
haircut and they're not sixty right you
know and then wearing rain boots on a
sunny day yeah yeah yeah and they're you
know there's something to about you know
this idea that you you look at people
now and you can almost tell you can
almost tell what conversations are gonna
make you want to kill yourself yeah you
can almost tell pretty quickly
what conversation is gonna make you want
to end your life yeah
or their life and you can see it you
could see in somebody's face they have a
certain expression I don't know I don't
even know how to describe it but it's
very severe they're like severe and
you're angry they're at war yeah they're
walking around Park Slope and they're at
war we don't know with what with systems
of oppression yeah unseen but they're
out there
yeah just holding people down everyday
yeah and uh and this is why but the
things I catch the most heat for on
social media is when I suggest to people
ever so delicately I do with a light
touch yeah look how many what a light
touch I go maybe we shouldn't all be
losers yeah because that's the real
people alike is it who is it is it like
Republicans that are out there or
Democrats or is it socialist or fascist
who's the biggest contingent of people
out there losers yeah like that's the
biggest contingent and if you tell those
people like I said a tweet that got me
in very big trouble I said Halloween
here's a way to stop offending people
with your costume don't wear one give
give the holiday back to children
remember what it was a child's holiday
yeah give it back to them buy property
start a family if you're a dude who
needs to go into a Halloween party
dressed as two twin towers with your
friend and you happen to be a
kindergarten teacher and you get fired
yeah you know give it give it to chuck
these what my grandparents never dressed
up my grandmother was never Danelle Vyra
costume what it tits out yeah it is just
wasn't the case yeah because she had
children and she cared for my parents
didn't take me to any children's movies
right
you know they remember being seven years
old and going to see reds and
jagged-edged was the father took me to
dead man walking yeah I remember going
to see jagged edge which was uh Glenn
Close in that and it was about I don't
know maybe it was about a murder someone
breaking into a house and murdering
somebody yeah I couldn't sleep for three
years after that right they just dragged
me into whatever our movie they wanted
to say that was
I didn't see Star Wars until I was 56
years old on my own you walk on the
Ninja Turtles no they didn't do any of
that yeah because they were busy working
they were on doors that built their own
business and they just I met them like
four times yeah
before college that's I my parents were
just not evolved a blur in a suit I was
raised by a Greek woman who did not
speak English she's an illiterate woman
she raised me because my parents were
working 24 hours yeah yeah but if you
tell people now if you say if you even
suggest to them that they take on any or
they evolve they take on any
responsibility that would be considered
like adult responsibility they always
tell you how wrong you are and there's a
lot of people that don't care about
their families yeah I know don't be one
of those either
yeah I'm not telling you to be that you
know it always fire back and they're
like you know my my father and mother
never should have had kids like you know
you're right talking to you I agree that
your mother and father's never should
have had kids I totally agree good point
yeah but I'm just saying I don't know
what people say all these people and I
have friends of mine that are so against
JD I'm having kids man what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do what are you gonna do
you're gonna hang out yeah till you're
60 you're gonna be a twitch streamer
well at 60 that's what that leg is I
like you're a 45 year old men yeah
walking around in in in socks and
sandals yeah high all day yeah twitch
streaming with a dog that they adopted
and their and they have like Arrested
Development and many of them are on the
spectrum some of them are to the
spectrum yeah and you know but if you
don't want to be uh you know an artist
walking around in a bright colored shirt
maybe it's time to get a [ __ ] clue
yeah yeah well you know it's it's an era
where I I have a friend who I went to
college with who's like a guidance
counselor in school and King of Prussia
in Philadelphia and she says it's
different she's a liberal open-minded
person she's like net well we went to
school you know the parents would side
with the teacher if I'm [ __ ] up in
school that go the teacher would say
they're doing this and they go why are
you doing this now she says the parents
come in and the kids doing something
they're going what are you doing
wrong to my kid why is my kid so it's
like there's has been this shift where
it's like very sensual everyone's trying
to get younger everyone's focusing on
the youth and blaming the systems the
older whatever the flaws of other things
and not the person it's like maybe your
kids just broken I wonder why and I hear
that for my friends that are teachers
too and I don't usually listen to my
friends at our teachers because I we all
know that teachers are in many cases
full of [ __ ] and they are they the I'm
kidding around I do give teachers a lot
of flack here because you know I'm day
it's not the hardest job in the world
right a lot of them are just the wives
of very rich guys it's a lot a lot of
people that are well I call them summer
enthusiasts that's what I call them okay
because it's you know everybody's like
it's the worst job in the world you're
out at 2:30 in the two best months of
the year
your ass is parked on the beach the
hours are conducive my husband makes 15
million so the thirty thousand doesn't
really move anything it's really matter
and I sit on the beach for two months
while all the kids and I spent time with
for a year go and do home invasions all
summer because I taught them so well so
but a lot of my teacher friends say to
me the parents now are always on the
sides of the kid I don't know when and
why that I just I don't know why that's
the thing maybe it's just this obsession
like you said with the idea that kids
are are or should be listened to well I
think it's this theme that like flaws
makes you nobody wants to admit flaws
right psyche when I was growing up and
not to glorify because there's a lot of
horrible things about those errors sure
behind us but it's like but there was a
more of a truth more of an honesty about
like my parents just openly telling me
that my brother was a smart one right
and when I got C pluses it was a
celebration right because I was just
stupider than he was right and they told
me that right so it was like that's what
it was right but me me knowing that was
like I gotta be funny so I was I was
kicked out of schools and I was class
clown I found something I was good at
it's like people who achieve things
achieve things because they accept their
flaws
and they say I'm gonna make this flaw
into something you know what I mean yeah
but if I got 18 I know kids are
energetic you're like give him pills
stop him from me and energy it's like no
put him on a stage yeah or do some
figure out what he likes yeah it's not
broken he's just not as smart as Jimmy
and that's not gonna be a lawyer now
everybody's got the measles cuz nobody
will give them the needle nobody gets a
vaccination because we've decided that
Jenny McCarthy is a doctor there's a
real war on science right now huge
there's a real that there's a lot of
people divided
well I'm along political lines yeah on
peer-reviewed science on both sides is
scary but I'm I say you know what I know
you have like the Journal of the
American Medical Association I say let
Jenny McCarthy and Rob Schneider have a
say and also Alyssa Milano yes yeah let
let them have a sec yeah let Jenny
McCarthy have a sir she should why not
listen to what does Tootie from facts of
life got to say about this
I mean Alyssa Milano was unused the boss
why why she on the news yeah Democrats
are like how could they elect Trump and
they're like yeah how do you let go
chump
cuz I'm following Alyssa Milano's tweet
yeah who's the boss yeah Alyssa Milano
is the boss we want to be led by
narcissists this is what we don't really
admit as a society yeah we like these
types of people yes we love avatars like
like Ocasio Cortes or Trump we don't
really like understanding systems or how
things work cuz it's complicated there's
like this diffusion of responsibility
the mortgage crisis perfect example if
you read any book about the mortgage
crisis it's really emotionally
unsatisfying because you can't come away
with any one group because everybody was
getting into the [ __ ] yeah everybody
okay yeah - Pete you go these people
weren't really victims number one you go
Wall Street we're [ __ ] liars as
they've always been the government was
doing the wrong thing everybody the
ratings agencies everybody got involved
but we we tend to not like that we like
these avatars like video games we look
at it like a video game so use Trump on
one side and then we have a Cosmo Cortes
we have one side we have a game show
host and then on the other side
somebody was a bartender yeah up until a
few months ago yeah of a bartender and
now we have a child star yeah Alyssa
Milano yeah has entered the fray yeah
yeah yeah I mean those are the main
characters these are the character those
are the main characters yeah oh yeah and
this is how it ends
this is what's so refreshing about
talking to somebody like you yeah is
that you understand that this doesn't
turn around no at all no no no this is a
cruise ship This Is It this is a cruise
ship and there's a frozen tundra head
yeah and in order to move that cruise
ship yeah we just the ship does not have
the dexterity to make a quick turn no
it's not a fighter plot it's not it's
not a [ __ ] speedboat it's not a
fighter plane
it's a 747 just packed with dumb fat
[ __ ] useless eaters people yeah and
you can't turn it so it's going dead on
into the iceberg that's it that's what's
gonna happen yeah it's a cruise ship
that's it it's too big and dumb and slow
to turn it's gonna be interesting to see
what happened you said that they're like
you can't we can't go you don't fix this
it did it's it's spinning this way you
can't you know I think one of the major
reasons you can't fix it is because if
you if you go out there and you talk to
a person just pick a person just pick a
person okay doesn't matter race religion
age pick a person and you talk to them
for a few minutes and you realize that
the my uncle said something once and he
said it would do his during Easter
dinner it was a little depressing it was
right after the Easter prayer but he
said he goes the people are too dumb to
be governed because they're too dumb to
be governed it won't work because if you
have people that are selfish rotten to
their core people this is what he said
during Easter because they're just
rotten to their core they want things to
consume they want for themselves they
don't they have no investment in
learning or knowledge they don't care
none of it matters to them so what you
do is you have only 10% of people who
care about acquiring that knowledge now
those people are craving sociopaths so
when those people have all of the
knowledge they weaponize it and then
they use it
against the bottom 90% who are just
trying to get Prince's
yeah that's pretty much what they want
they want pretzels and pools yeah he
likes floating in the pool and pretzels
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't ask
why we Libya why are we in Syria why are
we here why are we there
nobody cares so when you have a
population like this how do you conclude
it the world is so [ __ ] complex now
and the the systems and the things that
you have to understand otherwise you fly
out otherwise you fly out of the handle
you go you go join the Klan you go March
with a torch you know you used to call
yourself a communist you're walking
around Brooklyn saying comrade yeah
hanging out at some bar you just really
trying to get laid you're talking about
how great Marxism but that's what
happens if you don't want to understand
how complex the problems are well this
is why we can't win this the real reason
why we can't turn this cruise ship is
because all these dumb people were
talking about and look it's not to
disparage them it's just what it is it
is what it is just what it is that's it
those people are just a little slow it's
a little relay at the plate you're a
human right you know it's like okay we
thought he was an ape he's a human way
he got a finger on the plate just barely
slid into human just it's mostly what it
is during periods of industrialization
or whatever it is
those people are occupied with jobs
right so they're not out there trying to
find a Maya communist some of this it's
like those things are gonna be over your
head you need to get these people
occupied yes you need workers they need
something to do Rosie the Riveter they
need something to do right and in China
they have something to do right they're
all getting underpaid to make my iPhone
right and that's why China is winning
right because the masses are occupied
yes here the masses are on Twitter yeah
and they're trying to tell each other
what to do and who to follow right would
they need to be occupied and not with a
game of Thrones show now they need to be
working their head needs to be down but
there's no factories to do that there's
nothing to do that
the robots are coming there's nothing
we're gonna be able to do with nice
people when they don't have a job to go
to yeah it's gonna be bad
get up by the way Nate if you could get
up get up it doesn't have to be
immediately but I wanted to share this
with him get up like the top ten things
that were happening as Rome collapsed
cuz this is a great thing because I
looked at them again last night and I
was really amazed at how how similar the
Situationist to what we have now where
we're empire we're past peak we're all
over the world you know the dollar is
still the world's reserve currency for
how long we don't know
we are mortgaged I mean I don't know how
what is China owned now what do we what
do we twenty trillion in debt I mean
they just own everything
it's just something crying all levels on
all levels they on everything they got
their head down they're occupied in
there we think we're getting we're
getting the short-term money from them
we're getting the short-term profit for
the big guys like hey this guy's making
this for much less and they do it much
better
that's short-term because their whole
system is made to beat us well they run
like a company the whole country's run
like a corporation it's run like a
company they're a machine yeah and
machines like that they at they
culminate in trouble one way or another
it's gonna culminate in trouble yeah
it's gonna be we're ready to go to war
with Iran we're ready I don't even know
if you miss a day's news cycle now we're
in a war yeah you you Chinese war though
we do need a good one Iran won't do it
we need something bigger there's a room
somewhere right now sure with a couple
of guys yeah nobody knows their name no
nobody knows their name I don't want
anyone no I don't want anyone no they're
all right they're not on Twitter they're
not on twitch or not they don't they
don't got a blue checkmark no none of
that now they got another they got the
real blue checkmark that are invisible
right and they're in places you just
can't get into right right right yeah
yeah little private club action yeah
sure it's just at the top of an
apartment building that has gargoyles on
it yeah yeah hundred percent yeah
there's just gargoyles on the building
and they're up there yeah and there's a
lot of really fine oak in that place
yeah smell a scotch yeah and they're
trying to figure out what to do with
these people right cuz they understand
it right there above partisan politics
yeah they don't care they're trying to
keep this thing going so their family
doesn't get eaten by by these right
people right
you know they just want to keep people
out of Newport Rhode Island and they've
been doing it for you if it suited for
years and they figure out strategies how
to do it right they're like we got to
figure out a way to keep the animals at
bay out of Newport Rhode Island we can't
have a riot at the zoo we can't so
there's so sometimes yeah it just they
come to the conclusion we have just need
a war a little bit of a war I think even
sometimes they call up yeah the guy in
the other country I go listen listen
guys you need a war you need one and
then the guy goes you know what you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] me we need a we need one
yeah we need why do we need a war yeah
because we need to create jobs yeah
because right now there's no new thing
yeah if you were gonna be a part of the
tech boom you have to get educated yeah
that know our people don't want to do
that yeah cuz your people are making the
phones and it's like yeah they just it's
too easy just need a little conflict
they're all they're all [ __ ] they're
all majoring in English and yeah a B GGC
studies you nobody's in stem so just now
that we got it down sizes population to
create hundreds of opportunity yes or
just down one of our cuz a war is the
best tool for job creation we'll just
send the fighter jet over there will
down it ourselves
yeah and then we'll just get involved
because that's what we need to do it has
to happen once and it needs to happen
because yeah what how it's hard to count
on a plague yeah it's count on a plague
now because there's just people too
there's too much education
there's too much you know the the
standard of living is higher it's a lot
cleaner like a plague is really rapid
and you also can't control one if you
get like a real bad bird flu that could
start taking everyone down we don't want
that yeah yeah we need did you find it
day I have found a list that's eight
reasons why Rome fell and things in a
BuzzFeed list though yeah we don't want
that it was that we're gonna try to find
if Rogan had any of these producers by
the way he'd shoot them all in the face
by the end of the day if anybody at this
place was if Rogan had to deal with
these people for literally a minute they
would all get shot in the face he would
break their necks on camera yeah with
his bare hands he would choke the life
out of them yeah that guy that guy Jamie
is like it's like that's like the oldest
patient
it's like the shows being produced by a
aiya let's try to find we'll just try
this we're gonna try to find what was
happening as wrong felt like what was
going on is wrong felts okay we have the
whole rest of the half-hour to find it
yeah well what does the list say you
want to hear what the list says that he
got yeah everyone's being hard on it
maybe it could be a good list yeah I
don't think so but okay let's go with
your list what list do you have and
admittedly it starts for it but it does
there are some parallels in there the
list I want is when they're like when
they're talking about making celebrities
and a chef's okay Shaq like all the
things that are stuff yeah so you just
just poke around on there trying to find
don't work don't rush three four
episodes from now is fine
don't worry about I don't want anyone
here to rush this is my whole thing with
this network I don't want anyone I know
we have 75 shows we're producing you
know four or five of them have listeners
I don't want anybody to be rushed you
know we've got a lot of promising
Instagram shows that we've signed yeah
you know our CEOs wearing sweat pants
somewhere with a fourteen-year-old
Ukrainian I want to make sure
everybody's happy I don't I want to make
sure everybody's happy you know I don't
want anyone to work too hard to make
things happen you know right we've got a
fireplace that's unusable we've got what
we need yeah this is what we need yeah
we got we got track lighting like we're
on [ __ ] Coney Island Avenue what
Rasputin's the Russian bar underneath of
like a Dominican guys car this is what
you need yeah who would listen to a
podcast without track lighting like
you're at a sweet 16 in Bensonhurst yeah
I could use a little bit more air
circulation in here yeah we don't do
that we dock sejoon in here yeah we
don't need any of that yeah um but it is
it is it is wild man but they did do
that they started making deliveries out
of chefs and sort of that went that then
went that whole route because everybody
got really decadent yeah things are a
decadent yeah and then also when you
look at like the way the rich are
behaving now the rich are behaving like
they no longer inhabit the planet that
we do yeah they really are
aving like back in the day rich people
used to have to assimilate to a degree
yeah okay so if you look at all those
buildings on Fifth Avenue they're
beautiful they're limestone their
fortresses but they actually are built
to conceal wealth yeah much more than to
flaunt it yeah okay yeah yeah yes rich
people used to they're like yes they
knew they knew they knew we want it we
don't want them to know how much we have
too cute yeah people are gonna start
throwing rocks and they're gonna start
digging I like very much like
Frankenstein these people are gonna
charge the castle right so we have to
keep it down right right keep it down
you know what the whole wasp aesthetic
yeah Drive you know maybe a little beat
up older car yeah and now listen still
own the [ __ ] world but you don't let
anybody know right you know keep things
kind of bare simple plain yeah um you
know wasp food always sucked yeah it was
always like [ __ ] weird butter and
mayo based salads egg salad sandwiches
[ __ ] you know but you know the the
the Southampton bathing Corp which is
like the most elite 800 of the
wealthiest families in the country
there's no way see yeah it's not new
it's old looking and people like why
because there was something to the idea
of tradition and the idea of people not
appearing to be kings and queens yeah
like the countries they laugh and the
stuff that was really decadent was
beyond the understanding of the common
remember said the food is like I they
wouldn't want to eat it anyway yeah and
then you had a cigar sure made out of
the skin of like a Honduras girl yeah
that was wrapped in that yeah and then
you had like a scotch that was 400 years
old yeah the 14th pissed yes yeah he had
a mansion in Long Island a Newport but
it's never in somebody's face right you
don't put in if it was ever in
somebody's face you you wouldn't go up
to a kid would sit on his face because
he was cleaning the chimney and [ __ ]
hold your watch out and be like eh [ __ ]
yeah you don't do that which is why a de
macau and the people that make
succession uh did it's a good show but
they do some stupid things on that show
where they have like people taking off
their watches and giving them to
immigrant kids like
like it's just stew it's like they're
those Rick cuz what Hollywood likes to
do is pretend they're not rich yeah so
they create these characters of rich
people that are really evil except the
ones that they're friends with in LA in
Malibu cuz those are the good Pam know
what Hollywood those are the good guys
they like to pretend like they're very
liberal on the Instagram yeah and then
they get into their accountants office
and they'll say so how can we hide all
of this money so the government doesn't
give it get it to give our producers
check it back in what's up yes so this
is the list I've found I say this is the
seven signs of an empire and decline
interesting so we have debasement of
currency interesting economic crises
public shows to distract the populace
yeah chefs as celebrities emphasis on
food pleasure crazy apathy and finally
sexual obsession thank ya I mean I mean
could you could you spell out yeah porn
we are crazy with porn now yes and you
know Chris Hedges this guy wrote a book
it's [ __ ] free which is crazy it's
free there should be a struggle to get
it's never just people [ __ ] his
people getting choked out and
waterboarded and you know the Chris
Hedges who's a writer who wrote a book
it's a really fun book it's called
America the farewell tour yeah and he
went to the porn convention in San
Francisco and he goes the level of
violence and porn now is amazing yeah
just a level of straight-up violence
people feeling somewhat powerless and
sadomasochistic crazy violence well even
transport is it's created by the porn
industry right cuz trans they want to
transition fully most of them want to
actually have the surgery right but it's
like keeping the penis is like it's
decadent because it tricks the brain
like the straight brain right because I
watched these neuroscientists talk about
like you know animals uh the phallic a
hard dick like other animals used to see
a hard dick and it would get them hard
because they would want to compete with
the with the guy who just the whatever
animal just banging that chick
and so they put all those elements
together you know nobody wants to see a
porn with a small penis right you know
great guys aren't like let me see the
smallest dick yeah I want to see big
dick horse because it's just a sign of
like virality yeah
so the porn industry the people involved
like I don't want to do this right but
it's creating this kind of illusion yeah
this smell is illusion that people are
whacking it's not normal to stare at a
screen and whack off to something know
that there's it's not real and it's also
not normal to take a guy who makes
meatballs yeah and make him into a star
yeah like Mario Batali he was gonna run
rate that rate room this is how powerful
this [ __ ] was yeah forget Harvey
Weinstein I get Harvey Weinstein casting
couch he's got all this power in
Hollywood Mario Batali's making [ __ ]
meatballs and he's got raped rooms like
a king like Saddam Hussein yeah and
what's he doing making wild-boar ragout
but this is a decadent we are as a
country with fat decadent pigs worship
the food we just wanted charcloth nobody
wants to [ __ ] anymore they just want to
jerk off and eat a nice big ball of wild
boar raccoon
yeah people are a business and it
[ __ ] is gone way down amongst young
people nobody wants to sacrifice right
nobody wants to right like you said
create a family yeah for a kid no here's
here's what I realize we're yeah cuz I
just got married and we're gonna get a
have a kid and I'm gonna do that yeah
because what I realize is like what else
is there yeah and I was inculcated in
this thing that's my purpose there's no
purpose yeah I'm just lucky enough to
have a little charisma and be able to
[ __ ] right and so I don't have to
work like you got to work right but
we're just [ __ ] blades of grass here
yeah and just like blades of grass just
like strawberries just like [ __ ] ed
ed shares they all have one purpose
propagation yeah there's some things you
don't question with right why should I
have a kid cuz that's what you're here
to do that's we're all here to do right
you some things you just can't say
[ __ ] why should I do it
it's like cuz it's that's what we do
yeah look at every animal look at every
vegetable gonna be plant yeah that's
what this is
what's it that's what it is yeah so if
you're married and I have friends out
there that are married I'm telling you
right now he's exceptions but you know
what I'm saying if you don't yet listen
if you got a heroin needle hanging out
of your arm we're not talking to you
specifically right now yeah clean it out
maybe and then a few years down the line
you go yeah we don't want to deal with
your kids we're not we're not we don't
need that yeah
you'll need that but what I am saying is
that I have a lot of friends that are
married who aren't gonna have kids I can
tell you right now your marriage will
fail yeah
because getting married without having
kids what is the point GUP why would you
get married have no sense yeah no sense
what's the point of doing that yeah I
can have kids it makes zero sense it
yeah so all I'm saying is that I don't
want to be controversial I don't want to
make everybody mad I'm just saying if
you don't have kids you better be
[ __ ] really really good at something
yeah now many of you think you are and
you're not no you're not there's like 15
people who are yeah yeah yeah these very
very few people are going to have a
career that fulfills them on a level
where they don't need to have kids most
people want I'll tell you right now
Yanis we discuss a lot of things on the
show we talk a lot about what's going on
in the future what's gonna happen
resources are gonna be scarce people
gonna be fighting for food for water
company who's gonna privatize resources
water is the new gold all of that [ __ ]
we got special forces doing 90
operations a day in Africa everybody's
just trying to mine the last the lithium
ion from Afghanistan but I'll tell you
right now if you're out there and you're
a content creator and you're [ __ ]
doing it without a website you're [ __ ]
so what I need everybody to do that's
listening to this show right now is do
not worry about the coming cyber war
with China doesn't matter you gotta go
to ten Dylan's going to hell calm no is
tim t IM dylan di ll ons going to hell
calm that is what we're doing because
then you're gonna scroll to the bottom
of the site it's a beautiful site and
how do we build it we built it with Wix
Wix okay you go to the bottom you click
all the way at the bottom you click on
the link you can go to get 10% any
premium plan do you have a website it's
down right now it's down yeah you
probably paid for it right I paid for it
but you know websites are so yesterday
yeah go to my gram yeah but you know why
tickets which you're not yesterday I
argue with mr. pastor papas does not
want his content next to a picture of a
hot dog on his gram
everybody's got a website if website
yesterday why does Beyonce have one hey
probably doesn't have a Wix website but
you're not [ __ ] Beyonce sir shut the
[ __ ] up yeah go and start a website you
can start from scratch or choose over
one of 500 stunning templates they have
the world's most innovative drop and
design website builder so you can easily
customize your site just answer a few
questions I'd in know I'm supposed to
say yes I tuned out I don't know what
we're doing is it it's good yeah I could
have an organic to cement yeah
Beyonce's got a website okay yeah Wix
Adi is their artificial design
intelligence a few simple questions
about what you do will you if you are in
sales if you're an entrepreneur if
you're an artist if you're comedian if
you're a musician if you're in any type
of marketing or advertising you've got
to get your [ __ ] out there you gotta
have a website you got have a place to
put all your social media links all your
videos all your data you're just yeah it
is what it is many who don't have the
money to pay a web designer to build it
can cost fifteen hundred dollars you
don't have that kind of money okay cuz
you're still in the acquisition phase
you've got to acquire fans all that [ __ ]
you got to acquire a customer base you
don't have one you're [ __ ] out of luck
you're [ __ ] many of you yeah but very
easy 10% off any premium plan Tim
Dillons and whatever idea you have is
great yeah whatever it do you have out
there is great yeah do it make it into a
website yeah I'm sure it's good it's
great yeah I'm sure it's great yeah it's
unique yeah
and it's needed and what's holding you
back is you don't have a website that is
the only thing holding you back yeah you
had a website you the life you could be
living yeah right now with a website is
unfathomable to you make a website about
you watching Gary Vee right well I did
that don't do that don't [ __ ] go Jack
my [ __ ] idea for your own [ __ ] okay
okay but whatever it is maybe you are a
independent journalist yeah and you got
a lot to say about Venezuela right which
I don't I don't know why I have to give
a [ __ ]
yeah about Venezuela but everybody in
the coffee shop acts like they're on the
ground in Caracas
yeah with the info yeah I don't know the
answer to what Jay s madura should have
been Maduro should be the other guy I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't know yeah it's
not my problem right hey uh I don't know
do you know what's going on a minute I
don't even know a little bit yeah
I think everyone's lying because I don't
believe in the commies but I also don't
believe that the government should get
in there and but just put I hops in
there I don't know yeah I think I think
the people don't want Maduro they
predict might not yeah it's just yeah
you can't that only last so long you
can't hold people down yeah you can't
and that's what well I'll tell you right
now I will support Maduro if he throws a
couple of dollars against digital murder
I'm with you I don't think the people
need to have a say in every goddamn
thing
Maduro I'm with you I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I'm with you sir yeah if you come
to gas digital and go to Wick's you know
what Maduro is problem is he doesn't
have a website on Wix where he can get
his content to the people yeah he had a
PR problem he had a PR yeah and by the
way if you think we're murderers out
that we're not going to install another
hellfire your demon in there you're
wrong
yeah I'll tell you who but sometimes
that's good it is what it is I've
stopped care I'm looking if my father's
checked out he cares about wine and his
dogs yeah that's where he's at yeah and
I'm getting there too but I'll tell you
right now folks whatever the situation
is yeah you got to go to Tim Dylan's
going to hell calm no is Dylan's
di ll o NS going to hell you go to the
bottom you click on the link you sign
the [ __ ] thing up I get a [ __ ]
cent from this so all everyone do it and
I've offered this this is a fact and I
already have a few people if you do this
and you prove to me that you bought it
through my site you get to come on the
show for three minutes and pitch your
idea yeah cuz we got tens of thousands
of people let's get to [ __ ] on it I get
to [ __ ] on it or say that's a great idea
and I take it and we steal yeah digital
we do it worse than you were gonna do
win-win not so so here's the deal the
reality is you can pitch if you look at
a podcast you got a project sign up for
Wix you could come on the show three
minutes minimum we start the timer tree
I can engage you if you get to stay
three minutes I might keep you on for an
hour we don't know yeah so that
to reality if you want to get on the
show you gotta sign up for the Wix
premium plan then you can promote
anything you want anything you want on
this show for three minutes you come in
he'll what is it 120 seconds yeah 120
seconds of airtime a friend of national
audience to promote whatever the [ __ ]
you were doing that guy's a great deal
it's a great deal so Tim Dylan's di ll
ons going to hell calm go to the bottom
click on it
use the code now a lot of people message
me they said there was a problem with
the code so I emailed the ad people here
and you know so this is the DL well yeah
he was lol doing a spot at 3 a.m.
instead of [ __ ] figuring out the code
cuz everybody's gonna be a star that's
where everything works so well around
here everybody's pitched on the idea
that they are they are feet from stardom
that's why it's so good that's what you
want right you want to pilot in the
plane thinking that they're gonna be a
novelist write the [ __ ] novel while
you're landed in the rain at LaGuardia
that's what you want you know what a guy
that's accepted that he's a [ __ ]
pilot you want somebody who's diggin
that he's gonna [ __ ] like the world on
fire so he doesn't really need to pay
attention to what wouldn't landed here's
gotta get dropped but in his defense I
mean who would be is your dad sells a
guest did you if they didn't think they
were gonna be a star start Luis finds
these people on the street and Luis
thousand they're gonna be stars okay
you're gonna be a star you little bit of
stock you're gonna be a star what do you
perform to 5:00 a.m. you keep working
you lay at the 3:00 a.m. spots wix folks
figure it out thank you alright here's
our next add the ads are funnier than
the show yeah yeah oh the ads are better
than the show yeah well and I feel like
our conversation after this show we
should have put that behind a paywall I
agree with you that was a good I agree
with ya it's it's it's the thing it's
what it really is is now you just gotta
commodify your friendship yeah that's
how crazy now we're doing blue chip
folks a lot of people out there are not
having sex this is a fact they're not
[ __ ] this is when you were growing up
the whole thing was to try to [ __ ] yeah
it's too easy to get porn it's free it's
gotten you know right you just why would
you go try to [ __ ]
when you just [ __ ] pull your photo on
the toilet a public toilet jerk and
here's the other problem nobody's dick
works anymore because they've been on
antidepressants in stare for yeah so the
proneural of anxiety they can't leave
their house without a collection of
pills like you give someone in
late-stage cancer yeah they have a bag
of M&Ms different colored pills uppers
that even errs just to get themselves
into a [ __ ] place yeah so what the
happens is because I try to have sex
with kids in college all the time and
all these 20 year olds it just have
dicks that barely get hard they just rub
them against your leg because you're on
15 medication so they could write their
paper okay this is why we go to blue
chewed calm so if you're one of these
people out there are you getting groupie
dick yet now gay guy ain't fan dick I
want one guy one or two people over
Instagram yeah but it's only you know
one kids a screenwriter he's like 20
he's a screenwriter if you use their
like sucky dick but they're like I need
you to rent for me no they're just
they're just you know III attract the
type of dude that's not he's not gay but
he's not straight yeah he saw I don't
know what he is but he's trying to find
himself he's an artist probably you know
he's he counts buttons you know and it
stares at the Sun but whatever it is
blue true calm if you like sex and many
of you don't but if you do it's because
you don't have the confidence a blue
chip calm you can get the first
chewables there it's like viagra cialis
but it's a chewable fayed grancy is no
shame in using Viagra and Cialis lot of
people use it it's good it's good to use
it viagra it's good for you you got to
[ __ ] somebody the right way to eat to
keep them you know uh and and and blue
chew is a chewable okay you go online
there's no awkward conversation no
doctor visit it ships directly to your
door and discreet packaging you know
what I mean so you don't have to stand
on line and CV asked me some guy from
high school who's doing a lot better
than you he's dicks a lot bigger it
actually works he's got a family you
don't work I use these pills not to even
have sex I just wake up I look at my
dick and then I go right back to bed
blue to I wake up I see it I go that
looks good tonight and I go right back
to bed okay it so however you want to
use them it's okay
blue true gives you confidence in bed
every time you just got to go to be lue
chew calm promo code TD you pay for
dollar shipping and in discreet
packaging that's what we want you to
learn here at gas digital you don't need
to go to the doctor now if we just give
you CBD and blue chip yeah you take the
CBD if you're anxious and the backlog of
the rest of all the podcasts if you join
the subscription if you get to
subscription and get all of the archive
you know give you a bathtub full of CBD
you could soak your [ __ ] failed your
head in yeah and then you could get a
website with Wix and put all your ideas
and thoughts out there to the world yeah
so blue true calm is actually good I
like blue chip promo code TV yeah I mean
listen I'm gonna get some pills yeah I
make saddles yeah every [ __ ] needs
dick pills I mean America is just a big
buffet and I see no at this pots what it
is you pay 15 bucks up front and I go in
there get a crab leg and you just want
to put as much on your plate for as long
as possible it doesn't matter if the
food belongs with the other food now
doesn't matter if a crab leg and a
pancake or touching yeah doesn't matter
if maple syrup touching the crab black
yeah cuz it's all going down to sample I
remember I looked at a woman once I was
in a buffet in Long Island and I almost
vomited she had a nice big plate and
what she was doing what most people when
they're done with the circumference of
the plate at the buffet they are done
yeah once you filled out the plate
you're done this woman was putting food
on top of other food like like for
example potato salad was going on top of
like mashed potatoes a great he didn't
even make sense yeah I said there was
like are you not do you not get concern
with all the food mix around and she
look at me she said it's all going in
the same place like you're try like a
pig yeah in a trough you know people
looking for purpose there's no purpose
the honest nothing out there I just said
one of funny things I ever heard we're
on the cruise the Impractical Jokers
cruise and the the median wait on the
cruise about was about 440 pounds you
could take all the people off the bar
and it would be the weight of the boat
you could challenge the weight of the
boat if you could glue those people
together and they had some sort of
buoyancy and you can put them in the
water you could race here's a race the
boat
these are big boys and girls yeah
they had they had a scooters they want
scoot and then what scoot they'd go
right down a buffet in a scooter yeah
okay and Jana said to meet yours cause
here's what happens to these people he
goes when they feel a little air pocket
yeah just a little opening yeah just a
little Airport opening take her they get
panicked like I gotta fill this so they
just they stay in a constant state of
being full yeah it's great state
yeah they treat it like it's a breach
it's a breach in their security there's
like there's an opening there's a hole
it needs to be filled
yeah get back in there you know like the
Indian guys the Indian guys usually they
they've cornered the business yeah
waterproof and brick right with brick
you could waterproof the whole thing if
you miss one spot and water gets in it
could compromise the whole structure
buddy's [ __ ] that's how they look at it
there's a little hole in your stomach
and they're like it's got to be filled
yeah it's got to be filled or else I'm
not a whole person stat American ethos
of just more more MORE I want to really
go down to Cancun yeah to an
all-inclusive shore with AOC yeah and I
want her to tell me yeah with that with
a straight face yeah are you really the
first generation in America to live
without prosperity right at this so I
want you to tell me that I write at the
[ __ ] breakfast buffet yeah and it all
inclusive which is basically a carved
out oasis yeah in a poor country yes for
[ __ ] American yes who eat and drink
like Roman Emperor yes I mean the guy's
a bus driver and going down there and
he's eating like Nero and you're telling
me you're the first generation to live
without Prosperity she's she's
completely out of her mom I mean how can
you say that with a straight face yeah
well you know what it is it's the that
is the only thing that it takes to be a
politician is to safely missing
something shamelessly with a straight
fake that's literally what you have to
do if you want to get into politics it's
acting for people like a
she's cute but her teeth are [ __ ] up
yeah so she can't go to [ __ ]
Hollywood and be an actress but what she
can do is go on MSNBC until everybody
how [ __ ] they are and then it wasn't
their fault that they had 27 children
it's ok somebody else's responsibility
ok um
everybody came over to this country for
the most part poor yeah everybody ok
everybody and some people had more
advantages than others
poverty is where the human condition
starts from right you never really have
to explain poverty this is why people
get this wrong
Thomas Sol was a really smart guy talks
a lot a bit of the only thing you ever
really have to explain is wealth
prosperity how did you get wealth how
did you create this thing that hasn't
been around poverty is the species
originated stated in pop it's like
almost a natural status it's the way it
is yeah okay so everybody talking about
poverty is kind of missing it I
understand that poverty is a problem is
epidemic but I'm above above what you
want to do is how do you create wealth
how do you take people that are poor and
get and and the only idea that a lot of
these people have is to find people that
have money take their money which I'm
not against in every instance you have
to temper greed have to do it temporary
you have to do it but like somebody said
doesn't matter how many kids you have or
what kind of education you have you
shouldn't be poor hey buddy that's not
the work yeah that's just that's real
it's not realistic your politics just
aren't based in reality it's not
realistic that's not a real little
loophole right that socialists and
communists never mentioned right is like
that you can't make everyone equally
wealthy no because in order to be
wealthy right you have to be a
capitalist yeah so the only option for
socialism is to make everyone all the
same poor yeah if that's it you can't
well because wealth comes from capital
people don't talk about deep the the
very obvious differences in intellect
aptitude effort ability all of those
things you go you go in comedy the we
know geniuses who has not succeeded
because they don't give a [ __ ]
they have the date they're funny they
can write but they're not as aggressive
at securing opportunities for themselves
as they should be why who the [ __ ] knows
it is what it is just the way it is and
we all know people that have succeeded
wildly with definition that's talent and
but what did they do they they [ __ ]
worked their asses off and that was the
equalizer so this idea that you can
somehow create oh but now I'm not saying
like I think people should have health
insurance I think there's probably some
type of universal basic income there's
certain things that we might need to
have is practically avoid Mad Max yeah
cuz you live in a society you gotta make
us all work to avoid a Mad Max actuation
yeah but here's what you can't tell you
cannot tell people every day that
they're victims yeah you just can't do
it now not in the country where the
poorest people have advantages that
throughout the world poor people
throughout the world will look at our
poor people and be like astonished at
their at their level of so you you just
can't tell people that they're a victim
every single day how do blacks what
Charlottesville is it's a bunch of white
guys walking around thinking they're
victims yeah yeah because people are
telling them they're [ __ ] victim yeah
they're they're [ __ ] white guys
walking around a college campus they
think that Jews yeah have created a
country that won't allow them to succeed
yeah because no girl wants to [ __ ] them
because they don't know how to sit down
at a table without taking their [ __ ] out
or saying something ridiculous yeah so
that's what happens when you tell people
that they're owed things at their victim
right that's what that's that's how the
radicalization process have absolutely
I'm a victim yeah and then they start
focusing on the extremes yes and mistake
the extremes for the norm
yeah they look at this one thing though
all those people are like all of them
are like that yeah no you're just
mediocre less yeah and you have no work
ethic yeah you're just not that good
yeah it's not something that's people
fault when you look at a lot of these
kids that are angry there's a lot of
these all right kids yeah there they go
to
they live in a house that they don't
[ __ ] own they have access to the
internet cuz they're on it all [ __ ]
day talking about Jews yeah they're just
mad that they're gotten beaten by
Mexicans yeah that Mexicans will outwork
them actually walk them out there are
some guys that are better-looking than
them that are [ __ ] more yeah sorry
yeah go walk around a locker room yeah
you'll see people with big dicks people
with medium dicks little dicks dicks it
look like they were an electrical fire
yeah mister its veins wrapped around
exit look like they got have done and
put back together it to sit there and
say how do we make every dick yeah the
same you don't have you just got to go
into the world with what you have yeah
and so I have a big problem with this
whole idea of like and that doesn't mean
there aren't genuine there are genuine
victims out here yeah but we can't tell
everybody that they're [ __ ] every
millennial is ik will the mortgage
crisis I'm [ __ ] now I can on the house
cuz the mortgage credit my generation
got [ __ ] up with student loans nobody
told you to take out student loans yeah
you know yeah I mean and if they did
maybe you shouldn't listen what I was
saying about before about black people
and I don't even know if I've said this
before on a podcast on this podcast I
don't know about but it's like I don't
know how black people stomach yeah
hearing from like Asian and South Asians
yeah about how hard they have it I don't
even like yo your parents chose to come
here right your parents now are probably
doctors yeah you guys are crushing it
right you chose to come here yeah from
where you came from yeah something's not
right over there right and you're
talking about how much of a victim you
are yeah I mean how did it get away with
that cultural appropriation yeah that's
what it is yeah that's crazy significant
cultural appropriation I see is how
everyone has sort of stolen the the the
black struggle in America and which is a
real struggle 100 it was categorically
institutionally discriminated against
for and we handed that struggle out yeah
we handed it out to anybody person of
color we handed out to gay people now
it's like everywhere and everyone saying
yeah like no you're not yeah come on
better here that you have anywhere else
come and get it yeah everybody can come
sing spirituals now yeah yeah
it's disgusting yeah but what it is is
again it's just like just power factions
how to create how to create a base of
people that will give you power and if
you can create a group of people and
unite them and say people of color which
just means everyone which includes Asian
people which I never they're really the
same complexion I am yeah so I never
understood that
but whatever yeah and they don't really
tan some of them do but but I'm talking
about Asian Asians not south ain't right
now but if you just hold umbrella
people of colors just like everybody
that's not a white guy get in the boat
and what they don't realize is all those
people hate each other yeah they all
hate it
Japanese hate Filipinos they call them
the rats of Asia I don't do that they
did now all the Latin countries hate
each other tell everybody with the fifth
the Philippines has had 90 tsunamis no
one cares go look at the money they
raise it's like we're proud to raise
$600 for the philippi nobody cares what
happens to the Philippines how much it
is do you think is sort of the
inculcation yeah like overly left-wing
liberal arts institutions but if you
thought this sort of like oversimplify a
lot of it's that the white man is this
evil monolith and all other people lived
in peace yeah until Vasco de Gama got in
a [ __ ] you know what I mean all a lot of
it is that yeah but a lot of it such
horseshit a lot of lazy horse it's it's
it's pseudo-intellectual people that
don't know anything about the ancient
history history starts in the colonial
period they don't know anything else but
the problem also is a lot of rich people
have left the planet like there they
don't like they are looking at this
planet like a guy looks at a Kmart that
he is basically just about to shudder
yeah and he's staring at the people that
are all folding the clothes and he's
like well it's our last week guys hope
you've enjoy it and he's going to his
[ __ ] summer house and it's done
that's the way they're looking at this
planet wealthy people are done
participating they don't think you're
saying they used to they used to to an
extent they've looted they've looted
if they've basically said there's a few
there's some opportunities to make
really big money and it's gonna
potentially tear the country apart we
don't care we're not gonna fund things
like infrastructure [ __ ] that roads and
bridges good luck train systems good
luck they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care these rich [ __ ] are not
in the subway they don't give a [ __ ] and
if they do they're taking ironically to
have fun but they're in a car that's
being driven over to Manhattan Bridge
they don't care um so they care about
infrastructure they don't care about
health care they don't care about
people's health care that are care about
people's retirement plans they don't
care about the solvency of state
governments they don't give a [ __ ] they
just look at America is a big bank to
cash out they got investments all over
the world they're a global Jet Set
population there's different so why have
they forgotten that these people will
rise up and put their heading causing
everybody 600 pounds yeah that's their
that's who slow did you pick up this
buying fat yeah revolt yeah that's what
it is so that's so I'm family every
species needs a national every species
needs a natural predator of date and
poor people laughs are the predator of
rich people hundred for sale or people
too fat to chase down those rich people
the rich people are getting too
comfortable and that's why we're getting
all lopsided got buffalo mac and cheese
now buffalo mac and cheese for people so
they're not gonna get as angry they're
like well I got buffalo chicken pizza oh
yeah yeah we're mixing three types of
fat counts people dude they got foods
that don't even make sense you go to
Denny's listen to this this doesn't even
sound good they says it was so good they
have salted caramel banana cream
pancakes salted caramel banana it
doesn't even make sense look at the
drinks and Starbucks you're like postive
banana coconut mocha mint yeah nut it
doesn't matter and then if that's not
good enough you could chase those down
with a few oxycontin and really zoom the
[ __ ] out so the rich are no look they
don't even look at us like human being
rich peopIe read a lot about rich people
I do that [ __ ] show about them on the
tourists they their lives used to be
similar to the lives like middle cut
like the key like this
schools that rich people go to at one
point we're similar to the schools that
the middle class would go like they
would are always better but now it's
completely different everything's
completely private
okay well they don't travel on public
transportation at all they don't care
about the infrastructure of the city at
all they really don't care why does that
happen well I don't think that's
happened I think well the country has
part of the reason you says they're fats
they're not scared of them anymore it's
a joke it might be true he's
subconsciously true at least a part of
it is that I think part of it is also
that the country has become a lot more
diverse okay so what unites this country
uh at one point you had a group of
people there were all of a similar
ethnicity similar religions now you have
it's a global world right so you have
people from all over the world
collaborating with each other competing
with each other making money with each
other and people so you now have these
small communities so the whole national
community anymore is not as viable
because the things that used to unite
that community whether it was struggle
the Cold War World War two whatever it
was those things have gone away so
there's nothing that's an overarching
theme that unites anybody anymore go to
Louisiana in the backwoods of Louisiana
then go to San Francisco go to Portland
go to Rhode Island nice but why would
this be a country you talk to all these
different people it's it's almost like
you're in a different country
it's absolutely that case and so if
you're very very wealthy yeah your whole
goal is to continue to make more money
so you can make money here or you can
make money somewhere else and if they
got natural gas and Kazakhstan and
that's the move
yeah then guess what you're going out to
dinner with people from Kazakhstan gosh
and then you don't give a [ __ ] about
what's going on in America what
Americans need because you're not making
any money with America you're not
selling life cereal to Bob and Becky and
their kids in Omaha you're [ __ ]
talking a sheik about how to pump some
natural gas out of his Rock
and they've gone up to dinner Manhattan
or Miami hasn't that always been the
case though even to antics time in
England date they who Yellen went yeah
you know their companies went and
[ __ ] who listen EC India come and
look what happened to England now yeah
you know in decline oh yeah and it's
just a slow process that was a real
Empire that was a real Empire I was a
real it's a slow process at the climb
but these [ __ ] now do not look at
America as a country they look at it as
an opportunity to make money as a great
line from a book that Nelson DeMille
wrote he goes it's called the Gold Coast
it's a really rich guy he goes you know
I've been he's been I've been in New
York I've been in Miami I've been in
Beverly Hills you guys they've never
been to America right cuz I've never
been with met these [ __ ] don't give a
[ __ ] about Canton Ohio
right they don't care right now the
thing is they used to have to they never
really did they just have to pretend to
because their factories yeah yeah guy
Ryan right the factories were they are
they're tobacco farm or their sugar
Quantum's people that they were selling
[ __ ] to at least were there or they're
slaves right right now everything is
global and and and and and basically the
communities they create follow the
opportunity you know follow the
opportunities are in China
sure or Thailand or Sri Lanka yes so
that kind of makes sense 100% I care
less they care less about America cuz
they lost money invested oh your kids
can't go to college well sorry
yeah there's no more seaman Tommy Boy
where the guy gets up at the end at he's
like this factory this whole town
depended on this fact there's none of
that right there's none of that anymore
the people that own that factory sold it
years ago they don't eat they live
outside of that town they don't even go
near that town and Chris Farley's
characters now is doing H so there's a
hole in the balloon and our air is
pouring out very quickly yeah
it's seeping out and what won't be it
won't be out there by tomorrow but what
kept rich people in line was the idea
that they had to have some type of civic
virtue and social responsibility when
they keep their money go yeah when they
were they needed to you know pull in
political connections they needed all
that and they still need all that stuff
but they were doing business in America
their factories were in America that
consumers were in America but as the
world is but
global and and and and now technology is
really leveled you know this but I don't
want to say level the playing field but
it's enabled all kinds of partnerships
that didn't exist before people are just
looking out for themselves it's every
man from south there's this idea that
everything you even feel that in the
community level yes there's no
neighborhoods no not at all
people will talk to their neighbors
everyone in here nobody knows nobody can
no neighborhood no man what has happened
now is like you have to have a something
in common a hobby in common that just
communities form yeah you got like we
all have dogs we meet at the dog park
right we're all liberal yeah we're gonna
we're gonna meet at the quinoa shop yeah
you know we're gonna talk about his bob
mole are gonna figure this out yeah we
all take come on Bob we'll take 80
milligram oxycontin we go to the Wendy's
parking lot we all live in Old Hickory
Tennessee and we just [ __ ] we're
Christian and we don't like gays right
and that's it so we have all these small
communities a book out there called
Bowling Alone I've never read it but
people bring it up and they took about
the death of the American community and
and and and I basically you just have a
lot of lonely people interested that are
out there that are united by nothing and
then you have a lot of wealthy people
that are just it's a different world you
know I know some wealthy families in LA
and it's a different world they are not
they are not playing the same game
everybody else is playing yeah no I've
smelled them you know been around them
they know they smelled it you know they
smell like an anthropologist at all
times you and you there's there's no
passion yeah they're very they're
passionless it's very interesting yeah
but they got fine soaps they got great
sorry soaps but they don't like it's
very interesting when you talk to them
you're like oh you're unaffected by
everything there's no like there's no
like let me tell you they're just like
well you know yeah we just you know
yeah they don't they don't feel they
don't have passion no you can't yeah and
that's why these idiots like you know
these motivational speakers on Instagram
use Gary Vee Gary Vaynerchuk they're
their evangelical preachers right
they're the they're like capitalism
evangelical preacher and they're and
they keep telling people get it go and
get it go and drag it and [ __ ] it
whatever and listen
if you need to be told that your thought
you're hopeless well this is why it's a
[ __ ] sham yeah because all the things
were saying this is what I think yeah
yeah it's a sham because like we were
saying we're not all equal I find
yourself being unhappy yeah maybe it's
because you want to be Carson Daly and
you're not you're not gonna be you don't
have his hairline right you know his
family connection right you don't have
that sort of just even temper where he
can just deliver boring [ __ ] [ __ ] wants
to be him yeah you know he sat now what
not to talk to exactly some nightmare my
point is maybe you're trying to be
something you're not
right like why are you doing common
there's a lot of people with doing
comedy I'm going what are you doing what
what are you doing yeah you're neither
funny business savvy and aggressive or
funny right what are you doing give
nothing so we this country now this
American dream that's being sold to
people like go out there and get on your
own if you're if you're if you're
putting a clock you're doing it wrong
you're working for somebody else you
raise this [ __ ] punch that clock it's
like look there's nothing wrong with
having a job yeah not everyone's gonna
be a [ __ ] wine entrepreneur yeah
there's gonna be a [ __ ] podcaster it
so it out of a normal job I don't have
to find happiness in being an
entrepreneur yeah and [ __ ] going out
there and get in it you gotta be your
own boss happiness how about some fun as
mad as your family and your friends yeah
[ __ ] hobbies right start playing
chess yeah had a dog yeah you know you
don't have to be your own boss let me
tell you right now you don't have to be
wrong there's a lot of people in jail
right now waiting execution that were
their own boss yeah I know it's it
there's just the the we look down on
that like as the American Dream is all
about like come on man start your [ __ ]
it's like I can't start a [ __ ] right you
know what it takes to be Steve Jobs it's
a lot how it takes you have to look at
your daughter and go get the [ __ ] out of
my face
yeah I got [ __ ] to do yeah I got a phone
you know it takes a comedy all the
brains a whole from being adopted and
just an evil streak yeah that a lot of
people don't have a lot of people don't
have that evil street now and you better
go and get evil yeah the best the best
smarter the most successful people are
usually good and then the guy they got
an evil streak like a like they start it
in their underwear just a streak
yeah yeah just a little stress of streak
what do you think final question I love
when you come on because it's always so
happy it's all we said we're too
optimist you know with two optimist but
I think it is op they're like a utopian
I cannot have lunch with someone anymore
unless they fully understand that we're
on a sinking ship and if they do I think
we can have so much fun but if they
think that the ships gonna turn around
and everything's gonna be great
I find myself dealing with someone why I
would consider to be mentally ill yeah
because if you look at all the evidence
and you think that we're gonna write all
the wrongs
it doesn't mean you shouldn't try and
you shouldn't do the right thing by
people but all these people on Twitter
talking about compassionate they are
haven't spoken their brother in a year
so it's a lot of people that are full of
[ __ ] yeah and uh that is that that's the
that's the norm now yeah I mean it is it
is just just it is an orgy of [ __ ]
yeah people are and that's what the
Internet has done yeah people actually
believe they are who they say they are
on my gray you're not a great person
because you posted an article you got
retweeted you know it's like you're
going to brunch you're hosting an
article like where's se like okay are we
gonna get blood YZ right like you don't
care right and stop back in so much like
you do it's everyone it's this whole
thing nobody wants to have flaws in him
if you have a flaw they try to like take
your whole career away you say one wrong
thing if you mess up if you show that
you're human at all this mob who that
has formed and at all the mob the whole
the whole thing supporting the mob is
this [ __ ] that the mob is this
purity [ __ ] group right it's like that
scene in Game of Thrones not the booth
full circle right but remember when that
[ __ ] of that zealot took over the
city yeah that's what social justice
warriors are and you don't like those
zealots are you a fan of Thrones yeah
it's it's a great show it's a great but
I don't remember the plot lines yeah
cares like if you tell me what was what
happened season 3 or 4 I don't remember
him to do it you do remember what
happened on season 3 Game of Thrones
you're in a crisis you're in a crisis
I'm alright great Christ yeah you're
paying
I don't even know what you could tell me
season three or you can tell me the plot
of a whole nother fantasy novel and I go
oh great who's that it what do you want
to see happen cuz then I'll tell you
what I would like to see happen at the
end of the show is there anything that
you'd like to see happen well in the
world what I would like to see happen is
people figure it out
well I must John Steinbeck guy no I
think against all odds made him do
talking about Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones yeah I wanted to preface it with
that okay because I felt like we were a
little too [ __ ] negative May so I
hope I believe in a human spirit
yeah on Game of Thrones where I'd like
to see happen on Game of Thrones
my favorite character is Tyrion Gregg
yeah he's my favorite guy but this
season has destroyed him he's a [ __ ]
idiot now he's a good person he's not
banging any horse you know when it was
to watch a a dwarf climb on a
normal-sized girl [ __ ] and drink wine
hundred-plus and he was smart and witty
and now he's just like this [ __ ] he's
not he's not scheming he's a [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] for the dragon lady so sad and he's
stupid he keeps making all the wrong
[ __ ] decisions right all of a sudden
he cares about the people he cares about
says hey and the baby and his brother
and so what I'd like to see is him get
his [ __ ] annoying dwarf head kicked
off because that character's been ruined
by TV writers right that's what's
happened the first two episodes I liked
and now it's just so clear that TV
writers are trying to wrap this thing up
yeah cuz the money orgies over the money
or G's over until the movie
what's HBO gonna do when it's over till
the movie until to move it yeah they
well you know that's how you that's how
you you take it too far that's like my
course My Big Fat Greek Wedding the
sitcom you shouldn't have done it you
shouldn't have done it
walk with no wonder why why the reason I
like Game of Thrones is because the
beginning of Game of Thrones it was no
real clear-cut good guy you didn't
really know who you were rooting for or
why it was just things unfolding is very
interesting there's just different camps
and a lot of people [ __ ] their family
masks competing interest everything like
that I wanted I was this I've been a
supporter of Cersei Lannister for many
many years yeah a supporter of Cersei
she knows what needs to be done to lead
okay ah a supporter of her for years
yeah and seeing her get killed but in
the rubble of her building I can only
hope she finds a way to crawl out of
there I know she won't I think her and
Jamie are done yeah but God do I want to
see her on the Iron Throne coz I don't
want Game of Thrones to end with Jon
Snow or Arya on Iron Throne because oh
you know it's just that
happily-ever-after Disney [ __ ] the
george RR martin i don't think really
wanted i think he wanted like hey a
moral people can rise to the top and
stay there for a long talk and they
often do they often do yeah that was
great about Game of Thrones I was
realistic it was realistic in that way
and now this season we have Tyrion being
like both the people the innocent people
you know that's why how that's my point
like they all turned into these [ __ ]
fairytale Nurik I don't like it it's
[ __ ] some la writers room where
everybody's coked out and you see it you
can it's so easy to say so I liked it
Daenerys did a genocide I do like that
yeah she did a Hillary Clinton on
[ __ ] Libya I like that Canaris did a
genocide and I was I would have been the
guy in the writers room and said we need
a genocide who I don't care who does it
yeah but we need a genocide so I was
appreciative of that
now if anybody's gonna be on the Iron
Throne I hope it's Daenerys because I
want somebody who has the strength to
commit a genocide to be on the throne
not the girl the girl with the sword or
Jon Snow who's back from the dead which
is a [ __ ] you know I want an evil
person to win
she's Stalin basically she's at the app
right now well you know she's at the top
now yeah going into this episode we know
she's a man if Cersei comes back out of
that rubble and I know she won't but if
she comes back and somehow wraps this
thing up I would be eternally grateful I
know the executives listen to this show
not meaningful ones I love you Maureen
and I'm kidding but there are but there
are you know man I would just love this
because I can tell you what's gonna
happen
the last scene is gonna be Jon Snow Arya
and Sansa at the [ __ ] Iron Throne and
I'm gonna go man and then there's gonna
be a lot of losers out there that
and I just hope that when that happens
Circe walks in and cuts all their
[ __ ] heads off yeah and she sits down
on the throne and everybody looks at her
and goes you know what I'm with her and
then makes her inbred baby just like the
way they used to do it in Rome just the
way all those rulers were inbred just a
[ __ ] good realistic in that way Brad
small like a like a malnourished boy
King yeah like an inbred weird
malnourished boy king who looks like
he's you know eat bubblegum is entire
laia and that's it where can people find
you and your insights
if you Comedy Central no no you're not
gonna find a Comi central no no unless
you move to Canada yeah they won't even
let me put up the clips from the
half-hour special now they're taking
those down yeah take you to court they
take you to court and take the comedian
to court they'll take you to court
that's hilarious by the way yeah I just
tried to pull one up and it got take it
down they're gonna come you aren't doing
that now they're doing that wild yeah so
look it's 2019 you just put my name into
the Google that's it yeah it's pretty
easy
that's it yeah Netflix what Netflix yeah
what do you want you can find me on the
Andrew Schultz Network right right
that's where you can find folks I got a
special coming out yeah this is huge
yeah yes Andrew Schultz produced a
special and we're gonna put it up on
YouTube and it's gonna be free I'm
giving it away and it's uh just stay
tuned for it's called blowing the light
it's shot we're editing it and you're
free I'm just giving it away free
special yeah free special free free
that's it it's gonna be free and then
you're gonna think oh my ticket you'll
go buy ticket go buy tickets it's not on
them our of this business yeah so right
what it is I'm at left Boston this
weekend I would appreciate if you would
tell your friends there or not I'll
watch the Bruins game or the Red Sox
game yeah to opt out of those two
sporting events his sports a big dealer
I don't know and come over see me talk
about my aunt so I would I would
appreciate that
Tim Dylan comedy dot-com go subscribe
rate review this podcast la
calming folks were about done here we're
wrapping it up it's over we've had
enough the subway doesn't work
Uber's are $75 to get over to bridge the
infrastructure is buckling it's raining
every day now it's a tropical hellscape
and it's about to be humid sticky and
disgusting you'll find daddy in Beverly
Hills and eating a Pokeball eating a
pokeball and Beverly [ __ ] Hills do
not approach me with anything real if
you say anything real to me
I will look at you like you're insane
you come to me with a pretend idea of
what you think life should be
I will validate that and we will you
will stay on your way I bet you they
won't even recognize you cuz you're
gonna be slim I'm gonna be slinging the
green juice and I ain't gonna be funny
but I'm gonna be [ __ ] a cult of
personality you're gonna subscribe and
like it rate and review and show up to
hear what I have to say and you know
what I'm gonna have to say not a goddamn
thing but it's not gonna matter cuz you
don't have anything to say either we're
just gonna it we're just gonna sit in
the same room and stare at each other
and that's fine cuz we only got what 70
80 years on this [ __ ] floating rock
yeah it doesn't matter don't be a comedy
snob folks it doesn't matter could
anything be less all they feel that
write about comedy could anything be
less useful than critiquing a clown I
mean it's really crazy can you a man why
are they writing about comedy in the New
York Times well big why because they
what's going on because they can't write
about anything else would take research
let's just be honest journalism is in
crisis over it's right oh that's really
the crux of my father Donald Trump has
pretty accurately said the media is the
enemy the people I hate to say tax they
know people gonna get mad at me but with
Covington and Stussy and all these
[ __ ] things you start realizing oh
these people don't care about the truth
neither does Trump well you look either
to that let me just say it's about Jesse
smell that yeah real story the real
fascinating thing that everyone should
be talking about nobody is and what the
what that is is that people believe that
yeah that the media wrote about that
that that's the age we live in someone
can say this happen and it happened
immediate
every one the top Gazette's are going
this happened they don't wait for
statements and ok don't wait for
evidence huh they don't wait for
anything nobody's going woah this you
know while you're at it we're like well
we added up the time everything and it
had to happen within nine seconds yeah
it was it was true because he said it he
said it that didn't used to be
journalism cuz you know in New York and
Chicago in LA there's gangs of Trump
supporters running around I'm in what
you how many of these hate crimes and I
hate to say it turn out to be fake well
there's actually a lot of them try to be
fair is that one journalist who's Andy
NGO yeah he's somebody just attacked him
the other day I know he's been compiling
them he's got an interesting way through
like a milkshake on him in a gym yeah
and they also well and a March someone
sprayed him with mace in the face right
yeah so see this is the and people
wonder they go why does the rich not
care about cuz when an to fund the proud
boys all these guys beat the [ __ ] out of
your children streets rich people love
they adore that yeah because what it'll
just justify eventually is the martial
law crackdown because normal people
aren't doing that [ __ ] right so when the
rich people come out and um hey we need
these robot dogs patrolling the street
and we need everybody inside at 11:30
because it gets a little hairy out there
normal people go you know what I guess
they're right yeah
so all these people think of like these
little street skirmishers are the
[ __ ] answer because they think you're
living in I don't know a Russian novel
or something at the end of the day all
it will justify is the ruling classes
use of exorbitant amounts of violence
because they will dole out violence like
you cannot believe
the violence that they will use against
the population will will stun you so
when you look at all these people
fighting in the street and do it all the
[ __ ] in Portland you don't know that
that'll all just be used to justify some
real bloody behavior so keep it up yeah
keep it up we'll see what happens Tim
Dylan comedy calm for all your comedy
needs buy tickets left Boston Mohegan
Sun come up in June got American comedy
company in San Diego well be in LA
podcasters doing it twice a month I'm
doing some bigger podcast when I get out
there too
rate subscribe leave us a five star
review tell your friends about this go
follow your Ana's Papas yeah yeah I'll
be at the Miami improv June fourteenth
and fifteen yeah and listen to history
hyenas with me and Krista stuff history
hyenas great show Yanis Chrissy D
amazing show and I'll see you [ __ ]
from LA my next episode we were gonna
release Bennington next week and then
guess what [ __ ] I'm out next
time I talk you'll be face time it's
gonna be face time and I'm gonna be it's
gonna be famous time yeah it's not gonna
be an loss unless yeah a place where if
you have any of the discussions that we
had today people put you in a mental
home it's true look dad you can really
only get away with conversation like
this in New York
yeah put you in a straitjacket yeah but
they will talk about a showrunner
leaving this is us yeah but they won't
talk about civilization
unless civilization is a show on HBO
yeah burn down a couple months ago like
the whole thing was on fire
it almost burned down but when a city is
Hall is a wholly owned subsidiary of
Satan it'll always find the way yeah
maybe that's why I took a bath in flames
cuz Satan got a little dirty you need a
bad it's a city that shouldn't exist but
people forget the power of the Dark Lord
alright folks good night
[Laughter]